Ericka's temple of justice the Lincoln
Memorial which stood behind dr. King as
he spoke on that historic day dr. King
is gone felled by an assassin's bullet
but his words remain with us during his
magnificent life dr. King spoke not only
about freedom freedom standing alone he
spoke frequently about freedom and
justice and in his speeches he summed up
regularly the words of a Unitarian
abolitionist from the prior century
Theodore Parker who referred to the
moral arc of the universe the long moral
arc of the universe points toward
justice freedom and justice freedom
whose contours have been shaped over the
centuries in the english-speaking world
but what justice Benjamin Cardozo called
the authentic forms of justice through
which the community expresses itself in
law authentic authenticity and at the
foundation of those authentic forms of
justice is fundamental fairness it's
playing by the rules it's why we don't
allow deflated footballs or stealing
signs from the field rules are rules
they're to be followed and so I submit
that a key question to be asked as you
begin your deliberations where the rules
here faithfully followed if not if that
is your judgment then with all due
respect to prosecutors should not be
rewarded just as federal prosecutors are
not rewarded you didn't follow the rules
you should have
as a young lawyer I was blessed to work
with one of the great trial lawyers of
his time and I asked him did what's your
secret
he had just defended successfully a
former United States Senator who was
charged with a serious offense perjury
before a federal grand jury his response
was simple and forthright his words
could have come from Prairie lawyer Abe
Lincoln I let the judge and the jury
know that they can believe and trust
every word that comes out of my mouth I
will not be proven wrong and so here's
the question as you begin your
deliberations how the facts is presented
to you as a court as the high court of
impeachment proven trustworthy has there
been full and fair disclosure in the
course of these proceedings fundamental
fairness I recall these words from the
podium last week a point would be made
by one of the president's lawyers and
then this would follow the house
managers didn't tell you that why not
and again the house managers didn't tell
you that why not at the Justice
Department on the fifth floor of the
robert f kennedy building is this simple
inscription the United States wins its
point when justice is done its citizens
in the courts not did we win not did we
convict rather the moral question was
justice done
of course as it's been said frequently
the House of Representatives does under
our Constitution enjoy the sole power of
impeachment no one has disputed that
fact they've got the power but that
doesn't mean that anything goes it
doesn't mean that the house cannot be
called to account in the High Court of
impeachment for its actions in
exercising that power a question to be
asked are we to countenance violations
of the rules and traditional procedures
that have been followed scrupulously in
prior impeachment proceedings and the
Judiciary Committee the venerable
Judiciary Committee of the House of
Representatives compare and contrast the
thoroughness of that committee in the
age of Nixon its thoroughness and the
age of Clinton with all of its divisive
nacinda committee in this proceeding a
question to be asked did the House
Judiciary Committee rush to judgment in
fashioning the articles of impeachment
did it have carefully gather the facts
assess the facts before it concluded we
need nothing more than the panel of very
distinguished professors and the
splendid presentations by both the
majority counsel and the minority
counsel we asked some questions the
Republicans asked them questions we
heard their answers we're ready to vote
we're ready to try this case in the High
Court of impeachment what was being said
and the sounds of silence was this we
don't have time to follow the rules
we won't even allow the House Judiciary
minority members who have been besieging
us time and again to have their day just
one day to call their witnesses oh yes
that is expressly provided for in the
rules will break those rules
that's not liberty and justice for all
the great political scientists of
yesteryear Richard noushad of Columbia
observed that the power of the president
is ultimately the power to persuade oh
yes the commander-in-chief and yes
charge for the conduct and authority to
guide the nation's Foreign Relations but
ultimately it's the power to persuade I
suggest to you that so to the houses so
power to impeach is likewise ultimately
a power to persuade over in the house a
question to be asked in the fast-track
impeachment process in the House of
Representatives the House Majority
persuade the American people not just
partisans rather did the house his case
win over the overwhelming majority of
consensus of the American people the
question fairly to be asked well I cast
my vote to convict and remove the
President of the United States with not
a single member of the president's party
the party of Lincoln was persuaded at
any time in the process
in contrast and when I was here last
week I noted for the record of these
proceedings that in the Nixon
impeachment the house vote to authorize
the impeachment inquiry was
410 to 4 in the Clinton impeachment
divisive controversial 31 Democrats
voted in favor of the impeachment
inquiry here of course and in sharp
contrast the answer is none it is said
that we live in highly and perhaps
hopelessly partisan times it is said
that no one has open to persuasion any
more they're getting their news entirely
from their favorite media platform and
that platform of choice is fatally
deterministic well at least the decision
of decision makers under oath who are
bound by sacred duty by oath or
affirmation to do impartial justice
leaves the platforms out those
modern-day intermediaries and shapers of
thought of expression of opinion are
outside these walls where you serve
finally does what is before this court
very energetically described by the able
house managers but fairly viewed rise to
the level of a high crime or a
misdemeanor one so grave and so serious
to bring about the profound disruption
of the article 2 branch the disruption
of the government and to tell the
American people and yes I will say this
is the way it would be read your vote in
the last election is hereby declared
null and void and by the way we're not
going to allow you the American people
to sit in judgment on this president and
his record in November
that is neither freedom nor is it
justice it's certainly not consistent
with the most basic freedom of We the
People the freedom to vote I thank the
court
I yield to my colleague mr. purpura mr.
chief justice
members of the Senate good afternoon I
will be relatively brief today and will
not repeat the arguments that we've made
throughout but I just want to highlight
a few things there are a number of
reasons why the articles of impeachment
are deficient and must fail my
colleagues have spent the past week
describing those reasons in my time
today I'd like to review just a few core
facts which again remember are all drawn
from the record on which the president
was impeached in the house and that the
house managers brought to this body in
support of the president's removal first
the president did not condition security
assistance or a meeting on anything
during the July 25 call in fact both the
Ambassador yovanovich and mr. Tim
Morrison confirmed that the javelin
missiles and the security assistance
were completely unrelated the concerns
that lieutenant-colonel VIN Minh
expressed on the call were by his own
words and admission based on deep policy
concerns and remember as we said before
and everyone in this room knows the
president sets the foreign policy the
unelected staff implements the foreign
policy others on the call including
Lieutenant Colonel VIN moons boss mr.
Morrison as well as lieutenant general
Keith Kellogg had no such concerns and
have stated that they have heard nothing
improper unlawful or otherwise troubling
on the July 25 call second president
zalenski and his top advisers agreed
that there was nothing wrong with the
July 25 call
and that they felt no pressure from
President Trump president Solinsky said
that the call was good normal and no one
pushed me president zelinsky's top
advisor Andre your Mac was asked if he
had ever felt there was a connection
between the US military aid and the
requests for investigations he was
adamant that we never had that feeling
and we did not have the feeling that
this aid was connected to any one
specific issue several other top
ukrainian officials have said the same
both publicly and in readouts of the
July 25 call to ambassador Taylor
ambassador Volcker and others third
President zalenski and the highest
levels of the Ukrainian government did
not learn of the pause until August 28th
2019 more than a month after the July 25
call between President Trump and
President zalenski President szalinski
himself said I had no idea the military
aid was held up when I did find out I
raised it with pence at a meeting in
Warsaw referring to the vice president
the meeting in Warsaw took place three
days after the political article was
published on September 1st 2019
mr. Yermak likewise said that president
zalenski and his key advisors learned
what the pause only from the August 28th
political article and just last week
while we were in this trial alexander
Danyluk former chairman of ukraine's
national security and defense council
said he first found out that the u.s.
was withholding aid to Ukraine by
reading politico's article published
August 28th Mr Danyluk also said there
was panic within the vilensky
administration when they found out about
the hold from the political article
indicating that the highest levels of
the administration were unaware of the
pause until the article was published
and if that's not enough ambassador
Volcker ambassador Taylor Deputy
Assistant Secretary of State George Kent
and mr. Morrison all also testified that
the Ukrainians did not know about the
security hold until the political
article
on August 28th and we showed you the
text message from mr. your Mac to
ambassador Volker just hours after the
political article was published you also
remember all of the high-level bilateral
meetings at which the Ukrainians did not
bring up the pause in the Security
Assistance because they did not know
about it
when they did find out on August 28th
they raised the issue at the very next
meeting in Warsaw on September 1st this
is a really important point as
ambassador Volcker testified if the
Ukrainians didn't know about the pause
then there was no leverage implied
that's why the house managers have kept
claiming and continue to claim
throughout the trial that the high-level
Ukrainians somehow knew about the pause
before late August that's inaccurate we
pointed out that Laura Cooper on whom
they rely testified that she didn't
really know what the emails she saw
relating to security assistants were
about we told you that Catherine Croft
who worked for ambassador Volcker who
worked for ambassador Volker couldn't
remember the specifics of when she
believed the Ukrainian embassy learned
of the pause and that she didn't
remember when news of the pause became
public the house managers also mention
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh who claimed
to have vague recollections of fielding
unspecified queries about aid from
Ukrainians in the mid August time frame
but Lieutenant Colonel Feynman
ultimately agreed that the Ukrainians
first learned about the hold on security
assistance probably around when the
first stories emerged in the open source
and former Deputy Foreign Minister
Elena's er calls claimed that she knew
about the pause in July is inconsistent
with statements by her boss the then
foreign minister of Ukraine who said
that he learned of the pause from a news
article of which the August 28th
political article was the first as well
as those of all of the other top-level
Ukrainian officials I've mentioned the
testimony of the top US diplomats
responsible for Ukraine and the many
intervening meetings at which the pause
was not mentioned fourth
none of the House witnesses testified
president Trump ever said there was any
linkage between security assistance and
investigations when ambassador Sunland
asked the president on approximately
September 9 the president told him I
want nothing I want nothing I want no
quid pro quo before he asked the
president ambassador Sunland presumed
and told ambassador Taylor and mr.
Morrison that there was a connection
between the security assistance and the
investigations that was before he asked
the president directly even earlier on
August 31 Senator Ron Johnson asked the
president if there was any connection
between security assistance and
investigations the president answered no
way I would never do that who told you
that
Under Secretary of State David Hale mr.
Kent
an ambassador Volker all testified that
they were not aware of any connection
whatsoever between security assistance
and investigations the house managers
repeatedly point to a statement by
acting chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
during an October press conference when
it became clear that the media was
misinterpreting his comments or that he
had simply misspoken mr. Mulvaney
promptly on the very day of the press
conference issued a written statement
making clear that there was no quid pro
quo there's a statement let me be clear
there was absolutely no quid pro quo
between Ukrainian military aid and any
investigation into the 2016 election the
president never told me to withhold any
money until the Ukrainians did anything
related to the server the only reasons
we were holding the money was because of
concern about lack of support from other
nations and concerns over corruption
accordingly mr. Mulvaney in no way
confirmed a link between the pause
security assistance and investigations a
garbled or misinterpreted statement or a
mistaken statement that is promptly
clarified on the same day as the
original statement is not the kind of
reliable evidence that would lead to the
removal of the president the United
States from office and in any event mr.
Mulvaney also State
during the press conference itself that
the money held up had absolutely nothing
to do with Biden now why does this all
matter I think Senator Romney really got
to the heart of this issue on Thursday
evening when he asked both parties
whether there is any evidence that
President Trump directed anyone to tell
the Ukrainians that security assistance
was being held up on the condition of an
investigation into the Biden's that was
the question there is no such evidence
fifth the security assistance was
released when the president's concerns
with burden sharing and corruption were
addressed by a number of people
including some in this chamber today
without Ukraine ever announcing or
undertaking any investigations you have
heard repeatedly that no one in the
administration knew why the Security
Assistance was paused that's not true
two of the house managers own witnesses
testified regarding the reason for the
pause as Mr Morrison testified at a July
meeting attended by officials throughout
the executive branch agencies the reason
provided for the pause by a
representative from the Office of
Management and Budget was that the
president was concerned about corruption
in Ukraine and he wanted to make sure
that Ukraine was doing enough to manage
that corruption further according to
mark sandy deputy associate director for
national security at the Office of
Management and Budget we had received
requests for additional information on
what other countries were contributing
to Ukraine we told you about the work
that was being done to monitor and
collect information about
anti-corruption reforms in Ukraine and
burden-sharing during the summer pause
we told you about how when president
zalenski asked vice president pence in
Poland about the pause vice president
pence asked according to Jennifer
Williams what the status of his reform
efforts were that we he could then
convey back to the president and also
wanting to hear if there was more that
European countries could do to
support Ukraine mr. Morrison who was
actually at the Warsaw meeting testified
similarly that vice president pence
delivered a message about
anti-corruption and burden-sharing
we told you about the September 11 call
with President Trump senator Portman and
vice president pence
mr. Morrison testified the entire
process culminating in the September 11
call gave the president the confidence
he needed to approve the release of the
security sector assistance all without
any investigations being announced now I
focus so far on the house managers
allegation that there was a quid pro quo
for the security assistance let me turn
very briefly to the claim that a
presidential meeting was also
conditioned on investigations remember
by the end of the July 25 call President
Trump had personally invited president
zalenski to meet three times twice by
phone once in a letter without any
preconditions you heard that the White
House was working behind the scenes to
schedule the meeting and how difficult
scheduling those meetings can be the two
presidents planned to meet in Warsaw
just as president zalenski requested on
the July 25 call President Trump had to
cancel at the last minute due to
Hurricane durian president Trump and
President Solinsky then met three weeks
later in New York without Ukraine
announcing any investigations finally
one thing that the house managers
witnesses agreed upon was that President
Trump has strengthened the relationship
between the u.s. and Ukraine and that he
has been a better friend of Ukraine and
stronger opponent of Russian aggression
than President Obama most notably
ambassador Taylor ambassador Volcker and
ambassador yovanovich all testified the
president Trump's reversal of his
predecessors refusal to send the
Ukrainians lethal aid was a meaningful
and significant policy development an
improvement for which President Trump
deserves credit just last week
ambassador Volker
who knows more about us Ukraine
relationships than nearly if not
everyone published a piece in foreign
policy magazine I'd like to read you an
excerpt beginning in mid 2017 and
continuing until the impeachment
investigation began in September 2019 US
policy toward Ukraine was strong
consistent and enjoyed support across
the administration bipartisan support in
Congress and support among US allies and
in Ukraine itself the Trump
administration also coordinated Ukraine
policy closely with allies in Europe and
Canada maintaining a united front
against Russian aggression in in favor
of Ukraine's democracy reform
sovereignty and territorial integrity
Ukraine policy is one of the few areas
where US and European policies have been
in lockstep the administration lifted
the Obama era ban on the sale of lethal
defensive arms to Ukraine delivering
among other things javelin anti-tank
missiles Coast Guard cutters and
anti-sniper systems despite the recent
furor over the pause and US security
assistance this past summer the
circumstances of which of the topic of
impeachment hearings u.s. defensive
support for Ukraine has been and remains
robust and more according to ambassador
Volcker it is therefore a tragedy for
both the United States and Ukraine that
US partisan politics which have
culminated in the ongoing impeachment
process have left Ukraine and its new
reform minded President Vladimir
zalenski exposed and relatively isolated
the only one who benefits from this is
Russian President Vladimir Putin those
are the words of ambassador Volcker he
was one of the house managers key
witnesses he was the very first witness
to testify in the house proceedings on
October 3rd and so I think it's fitting
that he may be the last witness we hear
from in his parting words ambassador
Volcker admonishes that is his u.s.
partisan politics which have culminated
in this impeachment process that have
been
Harold Ukraine in some the house
managers case is not overwhelming and it
is not undisputed the house managers
bear the very heavy burden of proof they
did not mean it it's not because they
didn't get the additional witnesses or
documents that they failed to pursue
it's because their own witnesses have
already offered substantial evidence
undermining their case and importantly
as you have heard from Professor
Dershowitz and from mr. Philbin the
first article does not support or allege
an impeachable offense regardless of any
additional witnesses or documents
members of the Senate it has been an
incredible honor and privilege to speak
to you in this chamber I hope that what
I've shown has been helpful to your
understanding of the facts and I
respectfully ask you to vote to acquit
the president of the wrongful charges
against him I yield to mr. Philbin
mr. Chief Justice members of the Senate
we've heard repeatedly throughout the
past week and a half or so that the
president is not above the law and I'd
like to focus in my last remarks here on
an equally important principle which is
that the House of Representatives also
is not above the law in a way they
conduct the impeachment proceedings and
bring a matter here before the Senate
because in very significant and
important respects they didn't follow
the law from the outset they began an
impeachment inquiry here without a vote
from the house and therefore without
lawful authority delegated to any
committees to begin an impeachment
inquiry against the president United
States that was unprecedented in our
history the Speaker of the House does
not have authority by holding a press
conference to delegate the soil power of
impeachment from the house to a
committee and the result was 23 totally
unauthorized and invalid subpoenas were
issued as a beginning of this
impeachment inquiry after that the house
violated every principle and of due
process and fundamental fairness and the
way the hearings were conducted and
we've been through that I'm not going to
go through the details again but it's
significant because denying the
president the ability to be present
through counsel to cross-examine
witnesses and to present evidence
fundamentally skewed the proceedings in
the House of Representatives left the
president without the ability to have a
fair proceeding and it meant it
reflected the fact that those
proceedings were not truly designed as a
search for truth we have procedural
protections we have the right of
cross-examination as a mechanism for
getting to the facts and that was not
present in the House of Representatives
and lastly manager shift as an
interested witness who had been involved
in at least his staff and discussions
with the whistleblower then guided the
factual
we in the house so why does all of this
matter it matters because the lack of
the vote meant that there was no
democratic accountability and no lawful
authorization for the beginning of the
process it meant that there were
procedural defects that produced a
record that this chamber can't rely on
for any conclusion other than to reject
the articles of impeachment and to
acquit the president and it mattered
because the president in response to
these these violations of the
president's rights and to the failure to
follow proper procedure failure to
follow the law has rights of his own
rights of the executive branch to be
asserted and that's the president's
response to the invalid subpoenas was
that they're invalid and we're not going
to comply with them and the president
has started other rights of the
executive branch when there were
subpoenas for his senior advisors to
come and testify
along with virtually every president
since Nixon he asserted the principle of
immunity of his senior advisors that
they could not be called to testify and
the president asserted the defects in
subpoenas that called for executive
branch officials to testify without the
presence of agency counsel all
established principles that have been
asserted before now what did the house
manager say in response they accused the
president in their second article of
impeachment trying to assert obstruction
that this was unprecedented response an
unprecedented refusal to cooperate it
was unprecedented that 23 subpoenas were
issued in a presidential impeachment
inquiry without valid authorization from
the house the president's response was
to a totally unprecedented attempt by
the house to do that which it had no
authority to do they've asserted today
and on other occasions that the
president's legal arguments in response
to the subpoenas they've said that it's
indiscriminate
there was just a blanket defiance I
think I've shown that that wasn't true
there were three very specific legal
rationale
provided by the executive branch as to
different defects and different
subpoenas and there were letters
explaining those defects but there was
no attempt by the house to attempt an
accommodations process even though the
White House offered to engage in an
accommodations process there was no
attempt by the house to use other
mechanisms mechanisms to resolve the
differences with the executive branch it
was just straight to impeachment now
they have asserted today and on other
occasions that the President's Council
that I and my colleagues have made bad
faith legal arguments that are just
window dressing now in an ordinary court
of law
one doesn't accuse opposing counsel of
making bad faith arguments lightly and
if you make that accusation it has to be
backed up with analysis but there hasn't
been analysis here there's just been
accusation when the president asserts
the immunity of his senior advisors
that's a principle that's been asserted
by virtually every president since Nixon
and let me read you what Attorney
General Janet Reno during the Clinton
administration said about this exact
immunity she said that immediate visors
to the president are immune from being
compelled to testify before Congress and
that quote the immunity such advisors
enjoy from testimonial compulsion by a
congressional committee is absolute and
may not be over borne by competing
congressional interests end quote and
she went on to say quote compelling one
of the president's immediate advisors to
testify on a matter of executive
decision making would raise serious
constitutional problems no matter what
the assertion of congressional need and
quote was that bad faith was Attorney
General Reno asserting that principle in
bad faith and President Clinton
President Obama started the same
principle for his senior political
adviser was that bad faith of course not
these are principles defending the
separation of powers that presidents
have asserted for decades President
Trump was defending the institutional
interests of the office of the
residency in asserting the same
principles here that is vital for the
continued operation of the separation of
powers the house managers have also said
that once the president absurdities
defects in their subpoenas and resisted
them they had no time to do anything
else they had to just go straight to
impeachment they couldn't accommodate
they couldn't go through a contempt
process they couldn't litigate but the
idea that there is no time for dealing
with that friction with the executive
branch is really antithetical to the
proper functioning of the separation of
powers
it goes against part of the way the
separation of powers is supposed to work
that inter branch friction is meant to
take time to resolve it's meant to slow
things down and to be somewhat difficult
to work through and to force the
branches to work together to accommodate
the interests of each branch not just to
jump to the conclusion that well we have
no time for that we have to assert
absolute authority on one side of the
equation and this is something that
Justice Brandeis pointed out in a famous
dissent in Myers versus the United
States but has since been cited many
times by the court majority he said
quote the doctrine of the separation of
powers was adopted by the Convention of
1787 not to promote efficiency so he's
saying not to make government move
quickly but to preclude the exercise of
arbitrary power the purpose was not to
avoid friction but by means of the
inevitable friction incident to the
distribution of the governmental powers
among the departments to save the people
from autocracy that is a vitally
important principle that the friction
between the branches even if it means
taking longer even if it means not
jumping straight to impeachment is part
of the constitutional design and it's
required to force the branches to
determine incrementally where their
interests lie so to resolve disputes
incrementally and not to jump straight
to the ultimate nuclear
weapon of the Constitution we've also
heard from the house managers that
everything the president did here
asserting prerogatives of his office
asserting principles of immunity must be
wrong must be rejected because only the
guilty will assert a privilege only the
guilty won't allow evidence that is
definitely not a principle of American
jurisprudence
it's antithetical to fundamental
principles of our system of laws as we
pointed out in our trial memorandum and
border Kircher vs. Hayes and in other
decisions the Supreme Court has made
clear that the very idea of punishing
someone for asserting rights or
privileges or suggesting that asserting
the right or privilege is evidence of
guilt is contrary to basic principles of
due process and it takes on an even more
malignant tenor to it when that
principle is asserted in the context of
a dispute between the branches relating
to the boundaries of their relative
powers because what the house is
essentially asserting in this case is
that any assertion of the prerogatives
of the office of the president any
attempt to maintain the principles of
separation of powers of executive
confidentiality that have been asserted
by past presidents can be treated by the
house as evidence of guilt and here
their entire second article of
impeachment is structured on the
assumption that the house can treat the
assertion of principles grounded in the
separation of powers as an impeachable
offense
I mean boiled down to its essence it is
an assertion that defending the
separation of powers if the president
does it in a way that they don't like
and a time that they don't like can be
treated as an impeachable offense and
that's an incredibly dangerous assertion
because if it were accepted it would
fundamentally alter the balance between
the different four inches of our
government it would suggest and
professor Turley explained this
professor Dershowitz explained it here
that if Congress makes a demand on the
executive and the executive resists
based on separation of powers principles
that past presidents have asserted
Congress can nonetheless say we decided
to proceed by impeachment we have the
sole power and this is the principle
they assert in the House Judiciary
Committee report we have the sole power
of impeachment that means we are the
sole judge of our own actions there's no
need for accommodation there's no need
for the courts we will determine that
any resistance you provide is itself
impeachable that would fundamentally
transform our government by essentially
giving the house the same sort of power
as a parliamentary system to use
impeachment as ineffective vote of
no-confidence against a prime minister
not the way the framers set up our three
branch system of government with a
powerful executive who would be
independent from the legislature
that's why professor Turley explained
that the second article of impeachment
here would be abuse of power by Congress
it would make the executive dependent on
Congress and a manner antithetical to
the system that the framers envisioned
so why is it that there are all of these
defects in the house managers case for
impeachment why are they asserting
principles like only the guilty would
assert privileges that's not part of our
system of law why are they asserting
that if the executive resists the house
has the sole power to determine the
boundaries of its own power in relation
to the executive also not something that
is in our system of jurisprudence I
think it's because and why why the lack
of due process in the proceedings below
I think as we've explained it's because
this was a purely partisan impeachment
from the start it was purely partisan
purely political and that's something
that the framers foresaw and I'll point
to one passage from the Federalist
number 65 a number of different passages
from that have been cited over the
course of the past week but I don't
think this one has it's just after
Hamilton points out he warns that an
impeachment in the house could be the
result of persecution of an intemperate
or designing majority in the House of
Representatives and then he goes on
though this latter supposition may seem
harsh and might not likely often to be
verified yet it ought not to be
forgotten that the demon of faction will
at certain seasons extend his scepter
over all numerous bodies of men
now that's very 18th century language we
don't talk about demons extending their
scepter over men but it's prescient
nonetheless we might not be comfortable
with the terms but it's accurate for
what can happen and that is what's
happened in this impeachment this was a
purely partisan political process it was
opposed by partisan Lee in the house it
was done by a process that was not
designed to persuade anyone or to get to
the truth or to provide process and
abide by past precedents it was done to
get it finished by Christmas on a
political timetable and it's not
something that this chamber should
condone that in itself provides a
sufficient and substantial reason for
rejecting the articles of impeachment
members of the Senate it's been an honor
to be able to address you over the past
week and a half or two weeks and I thank
you for your attention and I yield to
mr. Sekulow
[Music]
mr. chief justice Majority Leader
McConnell Democratic leader Schumer
house managers I want to join my
colleagues in thanking you for your
patience over these two weeks I want to
focus on one last point we believe that
we have established overwhelmingly that
both articles of impeachment failed to
allege impeachable offenses and that
therefore both articles one and two must
fail this entire campaign of impeachment
that started from the very first day
that the president was inaugurated was a
partisan one and it should never happen
again for three years this push for
impeachment came straight from the
president's opponents and when it
finally reached a crescendo it put this
body the United States Senate into a
horrible position I want to start by
taking a look back on the screen is a
graphic of a Washington Post headline On
January 20th 2017 the campaign to
impeach President Trump has begun this
was posted 19 minutes after he was sworn
in I also want to play a video where
members as early as January 15 2017
before the president was sworn into
office were calling for his impeachment
I think that Donald Trump has already
done a number of things which legit
let me raise the question of impeached
by everyday until he is a beast I rise
today mr. speaker to call for the
impeachment of the President of the
United States of America the main reason
I'm interest is not so much to win the
Senate which is a byproduct it's because
I think he's committed a peacefull
offenses he needs to Scarl a lot I on
his chest but if we get to that point
then yes I think that's grounds to start
impeachment proceedings so we're calling
upon the house begin impeachment
hearings immediately why do you think
the President Trump specifically should
be impunity
well there are five reasons why we think
he should be impeached on the
impeachment Donald Trump would you vote
yesterday I would vote yes I would I
would vote to impeach because we're
gonna go in there I introduced articles
of impeachment in July of 2017 all I did
yesterday was make sure that those
articles did not expire I'm concerned
that if we don't impeach this president
he will get reelected my personal view
is that he richly deserves impeachment
one of the members of the House of
Representatives said we're bringing
these articles of impeachment so he
doesn't get elected again and here we
are ten months before an election doing
exactly what they predicted the
whistleblowers lawyer mr. Syed sent out
a tweet on January 30th 2017 let me put
that up on the screen the coup has
started first of many steps rebellion
impeachment will follow ultimately and
here we are with this body what this
nation and what this president has just
endured what the house managers have
forced upon this great body is
unprecedented and unacceptable this is
exactly and precisely what the founders
feared this was the first totally
partisan presidential impeachment in our
nation's history
and it should be our last what the House
Democrats have done to this nation to
the Constitution to the office of the
president to the President himself and
to this body is outrageous
they have cheapened the awesome power of
impeachment and unfortunately of course
the country is not better for that we
urge this body to dispense with these
partisan articles of impeachment for the
sake of the nation for the sake of the
Constitution as we have demonstrably
proved the articles of flawed on their
face they were a product of a reckless
impeachment inquiry that violated all
notions of due process and fundamental
fairness and then incredibly incredibly
when these articles were finally brought
to this chamber without a single
Republican vote
the managers then claimed that now now
they need more process now they need
more witnesses that all of the witnesses
that they compiled and all the testimony
that you heard was not enough that your
job was to do their job the one frankly
they failed to do we've already said
many times the charges themselves do not
allege a crime or misdemeanor let alone
a high crime or misdemeanor there is
nothing in the charges that could permit
the removal of a duly elected president
or warrant the negation of an election
and the subversion of the Americans
people's will and that should be
whatever party you're affiliated with
you're being asked to do this when
tonight citizens of Iowa are going to be
caucusing for the first caucus for the
presidential season election season for
the democratic party tonight I think
there's one thing that's clear the
president has had a concern
about other countries carrying their
fair share of burdens of financial aid
no one can doubt and I think we've
clearly set forth the issue of
corruption in Ukraine the presidents and
the administration's policy on
evaluating foreign aid and the
conditions upon which it's given have
been clear mr. popple laid that out in
great detail the bottom line is that the
president's opponents don't like the
president and they really don't like his
policies they objected to the fact that
the president chose not to rely each and
every time on the advice of some of his
subordinates even though he not those
unelected bureaucrats who work for him
were elected to office the president
under our constitutional structure is
the one who decides our nation's foreign
policy here is a perfect example the
house managers brought this up
frequently lieutenant-colonel vin Minh
he admitted on page 155 of his
transcript testimony that he did not
know if there was a crime or anything of
that nature
that's his quote but that he again quote
had deep policy concerns so there you
have it the real issue is policy
disputes elections have consequences we
all know that and if you do not like the
policies of a particular administration
or a particular candidate you are free
and welcome to vote for another
candidate but the answer is elections
not impeachment to be clear in our
country in the United States the
president elected by the American people
is in the words of the Supreme Court the
sole organ of the federal government in
the field of international relations and
foreign policy for our government
government no unelected bureaucrats not
unhappy members of the House
of Representatives and however you were
to define high crimes and misdemeanors
there is no definition that includes
disagreeing with a policy decision as an
acceptable ground to removal of a
president of the United States none
the first article form of impeachment is
therefore constitutionally invalid and
should be immediately rejected by the
Senate now as to the second article of
impeachment President Trump in no way
obstructed Congress the president acted
with extraordinary transparency by
declassifying releasing the transcript
of the July 25th call and the earlier
call it is that July 25th call which is
purportedly at the heart of the articles
of impeachment he did so soon after the
inquiry was announced and despite the
fact that privileges apply that could
have been asserted he released them
anyways in order to facilitate the
house's inquiry and cut through all of
it
all of the hearsay all of the histor
onyx to get the transcript out now I
want to take a moment because my
colleague deputy White House Counsel Pat
Philbin addressed this idea of privilege
I've heard over and over again in you up
to phrases like cover up the assertion
of a privilege is a cover-up here's what
the Supreme Court the United States has
said about privileges in a variety of
contexts to punish a person because he
has done what the law allows him to do
is a due process violation of the basic
order the basic sort and for an agent of
the state to pursue a course of action
whose objective is to penalize a
person's reliance on his constitutional
rights is patently unconstitutional and
how much more so when you're talking
about the President of the United States
how about this and this goes in the
context of assertions of privileges
other constitutional privileges the
allegation has been that if you assert a
privilege or assumed to be guilty that's
been the insertion
why why would you do that we've
explained at great length and I do not
want to go over that again the
importance of the executive privilege
and what it means to separation of
powers and the functioning of our
government but I will say this as the
Supreme Court has recognized in other
context with other privileges the
privileges served to protect the
innocent who otherwise might be ensnared
by ambiguous circumstances in another
Supreme Court case Quinn versus the
United States the privilege this Court
has stated was generally regarded Venice
now as a privilege of great value a
protection of the innocent the opinion
goes on to say in a safeguard against
heedless unfounded or tyrannical
prosecutions I traced for you and I'm
not going to do it again how all of this
started all those years ago three years
ago how all this began there is no point
to go over that because that evidence is
undisputed and the FISA courts most
recent orders put that in fair play we
talked about the fact that the house
violated its own fundamental rules in a
series of unlawful subpoenas I won't go
over that again mr. Philbin laid that
out in great detail but I do think it's
important to note that when seeking the
advice of the president's closest
advisors despite the well-known
bipartisan guidance from the Department
of Justice regarding immunity the house
managers asked act as if it does not
exist they saw testimony on matters
matters from the executive branch's
confidential internal decision-making
process on matters of Foreign Relations
and national security and that is when
protections are at their highest level
let's not forget that the House barred
the attendance of executive branch
counsel at witness proceedings when
executive branch members were being
examined notwithstanding these
substantial abuses of process the
executive branch responded to each and
every subpoena and identified the
specific specific deficiencies found in
each
you cannot just remove constitutional
violations by saying you didn't comply
you've heard that one recipient of a
subpoena and this is in fact we've
talked about it a number of times but I
think as we wrap up I think it's worth
seeing saying again one subpoena
recipient did seek a declaratory
judgment as to the validity of the
subpoena that he had received it was set
up to go to court a judge was gonna make
a decision
the house would drew the subpoena and
mooted the recipients case before the
court could rule that was it because
they didn't like the judge that was
selected was it because they didn't like
weigh the ruling was gonna go was it
they didn't mean to have that witness in
the first place
whatever the reason there is one
undisputed fact as the case was in court
they mooted it out by removing the
subpoena the assertion of valid
constitutional privileges cannot be an
impeachable offense and that's what
Article two is based on the obstruction
of Congress for the sake of the
Constitution for the sake of the office
of the President this body must stand as
a steady bulwark against this reckless
and dangerous proposition
doesn't just affect this president it
affects every man a woman who occupies
that high office so as we said with the
first article of impeachment we believe
the second article of impeachment is
invalid it should also be rejected in
passing the first article of impeachment
the house attempted to usurp the
president's constitutional power to
determine policy especially foreign
policy in passing the second article of
impeachment the house attempted to
control the constitutional privileges
and immunities of the executive branch
all of this while simultaneously
disrespecting the framers system of
checks and balances which designates the
judicial branch as the arbiter of inter
branch disputes by approving both
articles the House of Representative
violated our constitutional order
illegally abused their power of
impeachment in order to obstruct the
president
ability to faithfully execute the duties
of his office these articles fail on
their face as they do not meet the
constitutional standard for impeachable
offenses no amount of testimony could
change that fact we've already discussed
some of the specifics
I think Alexander Hamilton's been quoted
a lot and there's a reason what has
occurred over the past two weeks really
the past three months is exactly what
Alexander Hamilton and other founders of
our great country feared I believe that
Hamilton was prophetic in Federalist 65
when he Ward Howe when peach wouldn't
had the ability to agitate his words the
passions of the whole community and
divide it into parties more or less
friendly or nimma Cole wrote to the
accused he warned that impeachment would
and I quote connect itself with
pre-existing fractions and will enlist
all their animosities partialities
influence an interest on one side or on
the other he continued the convention it
appears thought the Senate this body
most fit as the depository of this
important trust those who best can
discern the intrinsic difficulty of the
thing will be the least hasty in
condemning that opinion and will be most
inclined to allow do wait to the
arguments which may be supposed to have
produced it in the same Federalist 65
Hamilton regarded the members of this
Senate not only as the inquisitors for
the nation but as the representatives of
the nation's the nation as a whole he
said these words quote where else then
in the Senate could have been found a
tribunal sufficiently dignified or
significantly independent what other
body would be likely to feel confident
enough in its own situation to preserve
uh nod and uninfluenced the necessary
impartiality between an individual
accused
and the representatives of the people
his accusers you took an oath they
questioned the off you were sitting here
as a Trier of fact they said the
Senate's on trial based on all the
presentations that we've made in our
trial brief and the arguments that we've
put forward today again we believe both
articles should be immediately
immediately rejected now our nation's
representatives holding office in this
great body must unite today to protect
their constitution and separation of
powers and you know there was a time not
that long ago even within this
administration where bipartisan
agreements could be reached to serve the
interests of the American people take a
listen to this take a look today we had
a beautiful bipartisan moment where
Democrats and Republicans working
together to keep that fentanyl out of
our country to use these devices to
accomplish that goal
it's not perfect we need to do a lot
more but today was a very good step and
I want to praise all of the people
Democrats and Republicans and the
president working together on this bill
and we can see by the people assembled
here if we work together part of the way
we get things done it this is a place
for all agrees that we've got to do more
and where we can work together so I
applaud everyone members we are proudly
joined today by so many members of
Congress Republicans Democrats who
worked very very hard on this bill this
was really an effort of everybody it was
a bipartisan success something you don't
hear too much about but I think you will
be I actually believe we maybe will be
over the coming period of time I hope so
I think so it's so good for the country
thank you everybody this was incredible
bipartisan support we passed this in the
Senate 87 to 12 that's unheard of and
then in the house we passed it 358 236
be here to help celebrate your signing
of this next step in this critical
women's growth and prosperity and
development initiative it dovetails
nicely with the build act bipartisan
bill you signed into law with the we Act
which recognized as this as a critical
strategy so I think this is a tremendous
an issue thank you so much I appreciate
it this is what the American people
expect I simply ask this body to stand
firm today protect the integrity of the
United States Senate stand firm today
and protect the office of the president
stand firm today and protect the
Constitution stand firm today and
protect the will of the American people
and their vote stand firm today and
protect our nation and I ask that this
partisan impeachment come to an end to
restore our constitutional balance for
that is in my view and in our view what
justice demands and the Constitution
requires with that mr. Chief Justice I
yield my time to the White House Council
mr. Petts of Bologna
Thank You mr. chief justice Thank You
members of the Senate I will leave you
with just a few brief points first I
want to express on behalf of our entire
team our gratitude our gratitude to you
mr. Chief Justice for presiding over
this trial our gratitude to you
leader McConnell our gratitude to you
Democratic leader Schumer and all of you
on both sides of the aisle for your time
and attention I also want to express our
gratitude to our team it's large and
with with a large number of people who
have helped in this effort I won't name
them all but I want to thank them for
their effort and their hard work in the
defense of the Constitution in defense
of the president in defense of the
American people's right to vote
I want to thank as members of that team
the Republican members of the House of
Representatives who have also been
engaged in that effort throughout this
tired entire period of time and the
Democrats in the house who voted against
this partisan impeachment and I also
want to thank the President of the
United States for his confidence in us
to send us here to represent him to all
of you in this great body and for all he
has done on behalf of the American
people I would make just a couple of
additional points number one as we've
said repeatedly we've never been in a
situation like this in our history we
have a bike a an impeachment that is
purely partisan and political it's
opposed by but by bipartisan members of
the House it does not even allege a
violation of law it is passed in an
election year and we're sitting here on
the day that election season begins in
Iowa it is wrong there is only one
answer to that and the answer is to
reject those articles of impeachment to
have confidence in the American people
to have confidence
in the result of the upcoming election
to have confidence and respect for the
last election and not throw it out and
to leave the choice of the president to
the American people and to leave to them
also the accountability for the members
of the House of Representatives who did
that that's what the Constitution
requires point number two and I think
that should be done on a bipartisan
basis and that's what I ask you to do
point number two I believe the American
people are tired of the endless
investigations and false investigations
that have been coming out of the house
from the beginning as my colleague mr.
Sekulow pointed out it is a waste of tax
dollars it is a waste of the American
people's time and I would argue more
importantly most importantly the
opportunity cost of that the opportunity
cost of that what you could be doing
what the house could be doing working
with the President to achieve those
things on behalf of the American people
is far more important than the endless
investigations the endless false attacks
the besmirching of the names of good
people this is something that we should
reject together and we should move
forward in a bipartisan fashion and in
the way that this president has done
successfully he's achieved successful
results in the economy and across so
many other areas working with you
on both sides of the aisle and he wants
to continue to do that and that's what I
believe the American people want those
of you elected to come here to
Washington to focus on to spend your
time on to unify us as opposed to the
bitter division that's caused by these
types of proceedings so we at the end of
the day we put our faith in the Senate
we put our faith in the Senate because
we know you will put your faith in the
American people you will leave this
choice to them where it belongs
we believe that they should choose the
president we believe that this president
day after day has put their interests
first has achieved a successful results
has fulfilled the promises he made to
them and he is eager to go before the
American people in this upcoming
election at the end of the day that is
the only result it is a result I believe
guided by your wise words from the past
that we can together end the era of
impeachment that we can together put
faith in the American people put faith
in their wisdom but faith in their
judgment that's where our founders put
the power that's where it belongs
and I urge you on behalf of those
Americans of every American on behalf of
all of your constituents to reject these
articles of impeachment it's the right
thing for our country the president has
done nothing wrong and these types of
impeachments must end you will vindicate
the right to vote
you'll vindicate the Constitution you'll
venda Kate the rule of law by rejecting
by rejecting these articles and I ask
you to do that on a bipartisan basis
this week and end the era of impeachment
once and for all I thank you from the
bottom of my heart for listening to us
for your attention and for considering
our case on behalf of the president I
come here today to ask you reject these
articles of impeachment reject these
articles of impeachment I thank you for
granting us the permission to appear
here in the Senate on behalf of this
president
and I asked you on his behalf on behalf
of the American people to reject these
articles thank you
mr. Chief Justice and Senators it's a
problem that here at the end of the
trial the president's lawyers still
dispute the meaning of high crimes and
misdemeanors some say it requires an
ordinary crime or that if the president
misbehaves when he thinks it's good for
the country it's okay neither is correct
we need to clear this up by looking at
what the founders said when the founders
created the presidency they gave the
president great power they just been
through a war to get rid of a king with
too much power and they needed a check
on the great power given to the
president it was late in the
constitutional convention that they
turned to the impeachment clause Madison
argued in favor of impeachment he said
it was indispensable Mason asked quote
shall any man be above justice of all
also that man be above it who can commit
the most extensive injustice Randolph
defended the propriety of impeachment
says quote the executive will have great
opportunity of abusing his power now the
original draft of the Constitution
provided for impeachment only for
treason or bribery Mason asked quote why
is the provision restrained to treason
and bribery only treason as defined in
the Constitution will not reach many
great and dangerous offences and he
added Hastings is not guilty of treason
attempts to subvert the Constitution
might not be treason as defined now
Hastings of Pietschmann in Britain at
this time was well known and it wasn't
limited to a crime they considered
adding the word maladministration to
capture abuse of presidential power but
Madison objected he said so vague a term
we equivalent to tenure during the
pleasure of the Senate so
maladministration was withdrawn and
replaced with the more certain term high
crimes and misdemeanors
because the founders knew the law
Blackstone's commentaries which made
Madison said was a book in every man's
hand described high crimes and
misdemeanors as offenses against King
and God
Hamilton called high crimes and
misdemeanors quote those offenses which
proceeded from the misconduct of public
men or in other words from the abuse or
violation of some public trust
during ratification Randolph in Virginia
cited the president's receipt of
presence or emoluments from a foreign
power as an example and Mason's example
was a president who would quote pardon
crimes which were advised by himself or
before invite indictment or conviction
quote to stop inquiry and prevent
detention detection it's clear they knew
what they wrote the president's lawyers
tried to create a muddle to confuse you
don't let them high crimes and
misdemeanors mean abuse of power against
the constitutional order conduct that is
corrupt whether or not a crime now some
say no impeachment when there's an
election coming but without term limits
when they wrote the Constitution there
was always an election coming if
impeachment in election years was not to
be our founders would have said so so
here we are Congress passed a law to
fund Ukraine to fight the Russians who
invaded their country President Trump
illegally held that funding up to coerce
Ukraine to announce an investigation to
hurt his strongest election opponent he
abused his power corruptly to benefit
himself personally and then he tried to
cover it up that's impeachable the facts
are clear and so was the Constitution
the only question is what you the Senate
will do now our founders created a
government where the tension between the
three branches would prevent
authoritarianism no one of the branches
would be allowed to grab all the power
impeachment was to make sure the
president who had the greatest
opportunity to grab power would be held
in check it's a blunt instrument but
it's what our founders gave us some of
the founders thought the mere existence
of the Appiah cause would prevent
misconduct by presidents but sadly they
were wrong because twice
in the last half-century a president
corruptly used his power to try to cheat
in an election first Nixon with
Watergate and now another president
corruptly abuses his power to cheat in
an election the founders worried about
factions what we call political parties
they built a system where each branch of
government would jealously guard their
power not one we're guarding the faction
was more important than guarding the
government opposing a president of your
own party isn't easy
it wasn't easy when Republican Caldwell
Butler voted to impeach Nixon in the
Judiciary Committee it wasn't easy for
senator Barry Goldwater to tell Nixon to
resign but your oath is not to do the
easy thing it's to do impartial justice
it requires conviction and removal a
President Trump
mr. chief justice
counsel for the president senators since
I was a little girl and started going to
church I've been inspired by the words
in Scripture whatever you did for one of
these least of my brothers you did for
me we're called to always look out for
the most vulnerable sometimes fighting
for the most vulnerable means holding
the most powerful accountable and that's
what we are here to do today the
American people will have to live with
the decisions made in this chamber in
fact senators I believe that the
decision in this case will affect the
strength of democracies around the world
democracy is a gift that each generation
gives to the next one
if we say that this president can put
his own interests above all else even
when lives are at stake then we give our
nation's children a weaker democracy
than we inherited from those that came
before us the next generation deserves
better
they are counting on us I'm the Catholic
and my faith teaches me that we all need
forgiveness I have given this president
the benefit of the doubt from the
beginning despite my strong opposition
to so many of his policies I know that
the success of our nation depends on the
success of our leader but he has led us
down senators we know what the President
did and why he did it this fact is
seriously not in doubt senators on both
sides of the aisle have
as much the question for you now is does
it warrant removal from office we say
yes we cannot simply hope that this
president will realize that he has done
wrong or inappropriate and hope that he
does better we have done that so many
other times we know that he is not
apologized he has not offered to change
we all know that he will do it again
what President Trump did this time
pierces the heart of who we are as a
country we must stop him from further
harming our democracy we must stop him
from further betraying his oath we must
stop him from tearing up our
Constitution the founders knew that in
order for a republic to survive we would
need to be able to remove some of our
leaders from office when they put their
interests above the country's interest
senators we have proven that this
president committed what was called the
ABCs of impeachable behavior abusing his
power betraying the nation and
corrupting our elections he deserves to
be removed for taking the very actions
that the framers fiop feared would
undermine our country the framers
designed impeachment for this very case
sinners when I was growing up poor in
South Texas picking cotton
I confess I didn't spend any time
thinking about the framers like me
little girls and boys across America
aren't asking at home what the framers
meant by high crimes and misdemeanors
but someday they will ask why we didn't
do anything to stop this president whose
foot hit put his own in
above what was good for all of us they
will ask they would want to understand
senators we inherited a democracy now we
must protect it and pass it on to the
next generation we simply can't give our
children a democracy if their president
is above the law because in this country
no one is above the law
not me that any of you not even this
president nadie estaba Sima de la nadion
this President must be removed with that
I yield to my colleague mr. pro mr.
Chief Justice members of the Senate two
weeks ago we started this trial
promising to show you that the president
withheld 391 million dollars of foreign
military aid to coerce an ally at war to
help him win the 2020 election and buy
many of your own admissions we succeeded
in showing you that because the facts
still matter we also promised you that
eventually all of the facts would come
out and that continues to be true but we
didn't just show you that the president
abused his power and obstructed Congress
we painted a broader picture of
President Trump a picture of a man who
thinks that the Constitution doesn't
serve as a check on his power but rather
gives it to him in an unlimited way a
man who believes that his personal
ambitions are synonymous with the good
of the country a man who in his own
words thinks that if you're a star they
will let you do anything in short it's
the picture of a man who will always put
his own personal interests above the
interests of the country that he has
sworn to protect but what's in an oath
anyway are they relics of the past do we
simply recite them
out of custom to me an oath represents a
firm commitment to a life of service a
commitment to set aside your personal
interest your comfort and your ambition
to serve the greater good a commitment
to sacrifice I explained to you last
week that I believe America is great not
because of the ambition of any one man
not simply BB because we say it's true
but because over our almost 250 year
history millions of Americans have taken
the oath and they meant it many of them
followed through on that oath by giving
everything to keep it but there is more
to it than simply keeping your word
because an oath is also a bond between
people who have made a common promise
perhaps the strongest example is the
promise between the commander a chief
and our men and women in uniform those
men and women took the oath with the
understanding that the commander in
chief our president would always put the
interest of the country in their
interests above his own and
understanding that his orders will be in
the best interest of the country and
that their sacrifice in fulfilling those
orders will always serve the common good
but what we have clearly show in the
last few weeks and what President Trump
has shown us the past few years is that
this promise flows only one way as Maya
Angelou said when someone shows you who
they are believe them the first time
many of us in this room are parents we
all try to teach our kids the important
lessons of life one of those lessons is
that you won't always be the strongest
you won't always be the fastest and you
won't always win there are a lot of
things outside our control but my wife
and I have tried to teach our kids that
what we can always control are our
choices it's in that spirit that hanging
in my son's room is a quote from Harry
Potter the quote is from Professor
Dumbledore who said it is our choices
that show who we truly
are far more than our abilities this
trial will soon be over but there will
be many choices for all of us in the
days ahead the most pressing of which is
how each of us will decide to fulfill
our oath more than our words our choices
will show the world who we really are
what type of leaders we will be and what
type of nation we will be so let me
finish where I began with an explanation
of why I am here standing before you
I've been carrying my kids constitutions
these last few weeks and this morning I
wrote a note to them to explain why I'm
here
our founders recognize the failings of
all people so they designed a system to
ensure that the ideas and principles
contained in this document would always
be greater than any one person it's the
idea that no one is above the law but
our system only works if people stand up
and fight for it and fighting for
something important always comes with a
cost
someday you may be called upon to defend
the principles and ideas embodied in our
Constitution may the memory and spirit
of those who sacrifice for them in the
past guide you and give you strength as
you fight for them in the future thank
you for your time
mr. Chief Justice senators and counsel
for the president this is a defining
moment in our history and a challenging
time for our nation a thousand things
have gone through my mind since this
body voted to not call witnesses in this
trial the vote was unprecedented
the president's former national security
adviser indicated that he was willing to
testify under oath before the Senate yet
this body did not want to hear what he
had to say
the president's lawyers have asked you
to not believe your lying eyes and ears
to reinterpret the Constitution and to
believe that if the president thinks his
reelection is in our national interests
then he can do whatever he wants
anything to make it happen and that's
exactly what he was attempting to do
anything when he illegally held
much-needed military aid while
pressuring Ukraine's President to
announce bogus investigations into his
most feared political rival this trial
is about abuse of power
obstruction breaking the law and our
system of checks and balances and since
we are talking about the President of
the United States
this trial is also most certainly about
character I reminded today senators of
my own father he worked more than one
job he didn't have a famous last name
his name appeared on
no buildings but my father was rich in
something no money
and apparently no powerful position can
buy you see my father was the man who
was decent honest a man of integrity and
he was a man of good moral character
the president's lawyer never spoke about
the president's character during this
trial and I find that quite telling I
joined the police department because I
wanted to make a difference and I
believe I did as a police chief I was
always concerned about the message we
were sending inside the agency
especially to young recruits especially
to newly hired dedicated police officers
we had to be careful about just how we
were defining what was acceptable and
unacceptable behavior inside the
department and out in the community yes
people make mistakes just individuals
make mistakes but we had to be clear
about the culture inside the
organization and we had to send a strong
message that the police department was
not a place where corruption could
reside where corruption was normalized
and where corruption was covered up
today unfortunately I believe we are
holding young police recruits
to a higher standard than we are the
leader of the free world if this body
fails to hold this president accountable
you
must ask ourselves what kind of Republic
will we ultimately have with the
president who thinks that he can really
truly do whatever he wants you will send
a terrible message to the nation that
one can get away with abuse of power
obstruction cheating and spreading false
narratives if you simply know the right
people well today senators I reject that
because we are a nation of laws Abraham
Lincoln the 16th President of the United
States said this America will never be
destroyed from outside if we falter and
lose our freedoms it will be because we
chose to destroy ourselves
I urge you senators to vote to convict
and remove this president thank you so
much for your time
mr. Chief Justice distinguished members
of the Senate presidents Council I
mentioned on the floor last week that
Alexander Hamilton has played a starring
role during this impeachment trial but
Ben Franklin has only made a cameo
appearance but that cameo appearance was
an important one when he made the
observation in the aftermath of that
Convention in 1787 that the framers of
the Constitution had created a republic
if you can keep it why would dr.
Franklin express ambiguity about the
future of America during such a
triumphant moment perhaps it was because
the system of government that was
created at that convention checks and
balances separate and co-equal branches
of government the independent judiciary
the free and fair press the preeminence
of the rule of law all of those values
all of those ideas all of those
institutions had never before been put
together in one form of government so
perhaps it was uncertain as to whether
America could sustain it but part of the
brilliance of our great country is that
year after year decade after decade
century after century we've held this
democracy thing together but now all of
those ideas all of those values all of
those institutions are under assault not
from without but from within we've
created a republic if
you can keep it house managers have
proven our case against President Trump
with a mountain of evidence president
Trump tried to cheat he got caught and
then he worked hard to cover it up
president Trump corruptly abused his
power President Trump
obstructed a congressionally and
constitutionally required impeachment
inquiry with blanket defiance President
Trump
solicited foreign interference in an
American election and shredded the very
fabric of our democracy house managers
have proven our case against President
Trump with a mountain of evidence if the
Senate chooses to acquit under these
circumstances then America is in the
wilderness if the Senate chooses to
normalize lawlessness if the Senate
chooses to normalize corruption if the
Senate chooses to normalize presidential
abuse of power then America is in the
wilderness if the Senate chooses to
acquit President Trump without issuing a
single subpoena without interviewing a
single witness without reviewing a
single new document then America is
truly in the wilderness but all is not
lost even at this late hour the Senate
can still do the right thing America is
watching the world is watching
the eyes of history are watching the
Senate can still do the right thing the
scripture says in second Corinthians the
fifth chapter and the seventh verse
encourages us to war
by faith not by sight faith is the
substance of things hoped for the
evidence of things not seen
we've come this far by faith and so I
say to all of you my fellow Americans
walk by faith
Democrats and Republicans progressives
and conservatives the left and the right
all points in between walk by faith
there are patriots all throughout this
chamber Patriots who can be found all
throughout the land in urban America
rural America suburban America
small-town America walk by faith through
the ups and the downs the highs and the
lows the peaks and the valleys the
trials and the tribulations of this
turbulent moment walk by faith faith in
the Constitution faith in our democracy
faith in the rule of law faith in
government of the people by the people
and for the people faith in Almighty God
walk by faith the Senate can still do
the right thing and if we come together
as Americans then together we can
eradicate the cancer that threatens our
democracy and continue our long
Necessary and majestic march toward a
more perfect union
mr. Chief Justice I want to begin by
thanking you for the distinguished way
you have presided over these proceedings
senators we are not enemies but friends
we must not be enemies if Lincoln could
speak these words during the Civil War
surely we can live them now and overcome
or divisions and our animosities it is
midnight in Washington the lights are
finally going out in the Capitol after a
long day in the appeasement trial of
Donald J Trump the Senate heard
arguments only hours earlier on whether
to call witnesses and require the
administration to release documents it
has withheld counsel for the president
still maintains the president's
innocence while opposing any additional
evidence that would prove otherwise it
is midnight in Washington but on this
night and all all the lights have been
extinguished somewhere in the bowels of
the Justice Department Donald Trump's
Justice Department a light remains on
someone has waited until the country is
asleep to hit Send to inform the court
in a filing due that day that the
Justice Department the department that
would represent justice is refusing to
produce documents directly bearing on
the president's decision to withhold
military aid from Ukraine the Trump
administration has them it is not
turning them over and it does not want
the Senate to know until it is too late
send that's what happened last Friday
night when you left home for the weekend
in a replay of the duplicity we saw
during the trial when the president's
lawyers argued here that the house must
go to court and argued in court that the
house must come here they were at it
again telling the court in a midnight
filing that it would not turn over
relevant documents even as they argued
here that they were not covering up the
president's misdeeds midnight in
Washington all too tragic a metaphor for
where the country finds itself at the
conclusion
the only the third impeachment in
history and the first impeachment trial
without witnesses or documents the first
such trial or non trial in impeachment
history how did we get here in the
beginning of this proceeding you did not
know whether we could prove our case
many senators like many Americans did
not have the opportunity to watch much
let alone all of the open hearings in
the house during our investigation and
none of us could anticipate what
defenses the president might offer now
you have seen what we promised
overwhelming evidence of the president's
guilt Donald John Trump withheld
hundreds of millions of dollars to an
ally at war and a coveted White House
meeting with their president to coerce
or extort that nation's help to cheat in
our elections and when he was found out
he engaged in the most comprehensive
effort to cover up his misconduct in the
history of presidential impeachment
fighting all subpoenas for documents and
witnesses and using his own obstruction
as a sword and a shield arguing here the
house did not fight hard enough to
overcome their non invocation of
privilege in court and in court that the
house must not be heard to enforce their
subpoenas but that impeachment is a
proper remedy having failed to persuade
this Senate or the public that there was
no quid pro quo having offered no
evidence to contradict the record the
president's team opted in a kind of
desperation for a different kind of
defense first prevent the Senate and the
public from hearing from witnesses with
the most damning accounts of the
president's misconduct and second fall
back on a theory of presidential power
so broad and unaccountable that it would
allow any occupant of 1600 Pennsylvania
to be as corrupt as he chooses while the
Congress is powerless to do anything
about it
that defense collapsed of its own dead
weight presidents may abuse their power
with impunity they argued abuse of power
is not a constitutional crime
they claimed only statutory crime is a
constitutional crime even though there
were no statutory crimes when the
Constitution was adopted the President
had to look far and wide to find a
defense lawyer to make such an argument
unsupported by history the founders or
common-sense the Republican expert
witness in the house would not make it
serious constitutional scholars would
not make it even Alan Dershowitz would
not make it at least he wouldn't in 1998
but this has become the president's
defense and yet this defense proved
indefensible
if abuse of power is not impeachable
even though it is clear the founders
considered the highest of all high
crimes and misdemeanors but if it were
not impeachable then a whole range of
utterly unacceptable conduct in a
president would now be beyond reach
Trump could offer Alaska to the Russians
in exchange for support in the next
election or decide to move to mar-a-lago
permanently and let Jared Kushner run
the country delegating to him the
decision whether to go to war because
those things are not necessarily
criminal this argument would allow that
he could not be impeached for such
abuses of power of course this would be
absurd more than absurd it would be
dangerous and so mr. dersh wits tried to
embellish his legal creation and
distinguish among those abuses of power
which would be impeachable from those
which wouldn't abuse a power that would
help the president get reelected were
permissible and therefore unimpeachable
and only those for pecuniary gain were
beyond the pale under this theory as
long as a president believed his
reelection was in the public interest he
could do anything and no quid pro quo
was to corrupt no damage to our national
security to great this was such an
extreme view that even the president's
other lawyers had to run away from it so
what are we left with the house has
proven the president's guilt he tried to
coerce an ally into helping him
by smearing his opponent he betrayed our
national security in order to do it when
he withheld military aid to our ally and
violated the law to do so he covered it
up and he covers it up still his
continuing obstruction is a threat to
the oversight and investigate Ori powers
of the House and Senate and if left
unaddressed will permanently and
dangerously alter the balance of power
these undeniable facts required the
president to retreat to his final
defense he's guilty as sin but can't we
just let the voters decide he's guilty
as sin but why not let the voters clean
up this mess and here to answer that
question we must look at the history of
this presidency and to the character of
this president or lack of character and
ask can we be confident that he will not
continue to try to cheat in that very
election can we be confident that
Americans and not foreign powers will
get to decide and that the president was
shun any further foreign interference in
our democratic affairs and the short
plain sad incontestable answer is no you
can't you can't trust this president to
do the right thing not for one minute
not for one election not for the sake of
our country you just can't he will not
change and you know it in 2016 he
invited foreign interference in our
election hey Russia if you're listening
hack Hillary's emails he said and they
did immediately and when the Russians
started dumping them before the election
he made use of them in every conceivable
way touting the filthy lucre at campaign
stops more than a hundred times when he
was investigated he did everything he
could to obstruct justice going so far
as to fire the FBI director and try to
fire the special counsel and ask the
White House Counsel to law
on his behalf during the same campaign
while telling the country he had no
business dealings with Russia he was
continuing to actively pursue the most
lucrative deal of his life a trump tower
in the heart of Moscow six close
associates of the president would be
indicted or go to jail in connection
with the president's campaign Russia and
the effort to cover it up on the day
after that tragic chapter appeared to
come to an end
with Bob Miller's testimony Donald Trump
was back on the phone this time with
another foreign power Ukraine and once
again seeking foreign help with his
election only this time he had the full
powers of the presidency at his disposal
this time he could use coercion this
time he could withhold aid from a nation
whose soldiers were dying every week
this time he believed he could do
whatever he wanted under Article two and
this time when he was caught he could
make sure that the Justice Department
would never investigate the matter and
they didn't Donald Trump had no more
Jeff Sessions he had just the man he
wanted in Bill Barr a man whose view of
the imperial presidency a presidency in
which the Department of Justice is
little more than an extension of the
White House Council is to do the
president's bidding so Congress had to
do the investigation itself and just as
before he obstructed that investigation
in every way he has not changed he will
not change he has made that clear
himself without self-awareness or
hesitation a man without character or
ethical compass will never find his way
even as the most recent and most
egregious misconduct was discovered he
was unpolished and more dangerous
undeterred he continued pressing Ukraine
to smear his rivals even as the
investigation was under way he invited
new countries to get involved in the act
calling on China to do the same his
personal emissary rudy guiliani
dispatched himself to ukraine trying to
get further foreign interference in our
election the plot goes on the scheming
persists and the danger will never
recede he has done it before he will do
it again what are the odds if left in
office that he will continue trying to
cheat I will tell you 100% not five not
ten or even fifty but 100% if you have
found him guilty and you do not remove
him from office he will continue trying
to cheat in the election until he
succeeds then what shall you say what
shall you say if Russia again interferes
in our election and Donald Trump does
nothing but celebrate their efforts what
shall you say if Ukraine capitulates and
announces investigations into the
presence rivals what shall you say in
future when candidates compete for the
allegiant of foreign powers in their
elections when they draft their platform
so to encourage foreign intervention in
their campaign foreign nations as the
most super of super PACs
of them all if not legal somehow
permissible because Donald Trump has
made it so and we refuse to do anything
about it but wring our hands they'll
hack your opponent's emails the amount
of social media campaign to support you
they'll announce investigations of your
opponent to help you and all for the
asking leave Donald Trump in office
after you have found him guilty and this
is the future that you will invite now
we have known since the day we brought
these charges that the bar to conviction
requiring fully two-thirds of the Senate
may be prohibitively high and yet the
alternative is a runaway presidency and
a nation whose elections are open to the
highest bidder
and so you might ask
how given the gravity of the presents
misconduct given the abundance of
evidence of his guilt given the
acknowledgment by senators in both
parties of that guilt how have we
arrived here with so little common
ground
why was the Nixon impeachment bipartisan
why was the Clinton impeachment much
less so and why is the gulf between the
parties even greater today it is not for
the reason the president's lawyers would
have you believe although they have
claimed many times in many ways that the
process and the house was flawed because
we did not allow the President to
control it it was in reality little
different than the process in Prior
impeachments the circumstances of course
were different the Watergate
investigation began in the Senate and it
progressed before it got moving in the
house and there of course much of the
investigative work had been done by the
special prosecutor Leon Jaworski in
Clinton there was likewise an
independent council that conducted a
multi-year investigation that started
with a real estate deal in Arkansas and
ended with a blue dress Nixon and
Clinton of course played no role in
those investigations before they moved
to the House Judiciary Committee but to
the degree you can compare the process
when it got to the Judiciary Committee
in either prior and recent impeachments
it was largely the same as we have here
the President had the right to call
witnesses to ask questions and chose not
to the house majorities and Nixon and
Clinton did not see their subpoena power
to their minorities and neither did we
here although then as now we gave the
minority the right to request subpoenas
and to compel a vote and they did so the
due process the house presided here
provided here was essentially the same
and in some ways even greater
nevertheless the president's council
hopes that through sheer repetition they
can convert non truth into truth do not
let them every single court to hear mr.
Philbin's arguments has rejected them
the subpoenas are invalid rejected by
the McGann Court they have absolute
immunity rejected by the McGann Court
privilege may conceal crime or fraud
rejected by the court in Nixon but if
the process here was substantially the
same the facts of the president's
misconduct were very different from one
impeachment to the next the Republican
Party of Nixon's time broke into the DNC
and the president covered it up Nixon
too abused the power of his office to
gain an unfair advantage over his
opponent but in Watergate he never
sought to coerce a foreign power to aid
his reelection nor did he sacrifice our
national security in such a palpable and
destructive way as withholding aid from
an ally at war and he certainly did not
engage in the wholesale obstruction of
Congress or justice that we have seen
this president commitment the facts of
the present Clinton's misconduct pale in
comparison to Nixon and do not hold a
candle to Donald Trump lying about an
affair is morally wrong and when under
oath it is a crime but it had nothing to
do with his duties in office the process
being the same the facts of president
Trump's misconduct being far more
destructive than either past president
what then it counts for the disparate
result in bipartisan support for his
removal what has changed
the short answer is we have changed the
members of Congress have changed for
reasons as varied as the Stars the
members of this body and ours in the
house are now far more accepting of the
most serious misconduct of a president
as long as it is a president of one's
own party and that is a trend most
dangerous for our country 50 years ago
no lawyer representing the president
would have ever made the outlandish
argument that if the President believes
his corruption will serve to get him
elected whether it is by coercing an
ally to help him cheat or in any other
form that he may not be impeached that
this is somehow a permissible use of his
power but here we are the argument has
been made and some appear ready to
accept it and that is dangerous for
there is no limiting principle to that
position it must have come as a shock a
pleasant shock to this precedent that
our norms and institutions would prove
to be so weak the independence of the
Justice Department and its formerly
proud office of legal counsel now mere
legal tools at the president's disposal
to investigate enemies or churn out
helpful opinions not worth the paper
they are written on the FBI painted by a
president as corrupt and disloyal the
intelligence community not to be trusted
against the good counsel of Vladimir
Putin the press portrayed as enemies of
the people the daily attacks on the
guardrails of our democracy so
relentlessly assailed have made us numb
and blind to the consequences does none
of that matter anymore if he's the
president of our party I hope and pray
that we never have a president like
Donald Trump in the Democratic Party one
that would betray the national interests
in the country's security to help with
his re-election and I would hope to god
that if we did we would impeach him and
Democrats would lead the way but I
suppose you never know just how
difficult that is until you are
confronted with it but you my friends
are confronted with it you are
confronted with that difficulty now and
you must not shrink from it history will
not be kind to Donald Trump I think we
all know that not because it will be
written by never Trump errs but because
whenever we have departed
from the values of our nation we have
come to regret it and that regret is
written all over the pages of our
history if you find that the house has
proved its case and still vote to acquit
your name will be tied to his with a
cord of Steel and for all of history but
if you find the courage to stand up to
him to speak the awful truth to his rank
falsehood your place will be among the
David's who took on Goliath if only you
will say enough we Revere the wisdom of
our founders and the insights they had
into self-governance we scour their
words for hidden meeting and try to
place ourselves in their shoes but we
have one advantage that the founders did
not for all their genius they could not
see but opaquely into the future we on
the other hand at the advantage of time
of seeing how their great experiment and
self-governance has progressed when we
look at the sweep of history there are
times when our nation and the rest of
the world have moved with a seemingly
irresistible force in the direction of
greater freedom more freedom to speak
and to assemble to practice our faith
and tolerate the faith of others to love
whom we would and choose love over hate
more free societies walls tumbling down
nations reborn but then like a pendulum
approaching the end of its arc the
outward movement begins to arrest the
golden globe of freedom reaches its
zenith and starts to retreat the
pendulum swings back past the center and
recedes into a dark unknown how much
farther will travel in its illiberal
direction how many more freedoms will be
extinguished before it turns back we
cannot say but what we do here in this
moment will affect its course and its
correction every single vote even a
single vote by a single member can
change the core
of history it is said that a single man
or woman of courage makes a majority is
there one among you who will say enough
America believes a thing called truth
she does not believe we are entitled to
our own alternate facts she recoils at
those who spread pernicious falsehoods
to her truth matters there is nothing
more corrosive to a democracy than the
idea that there is no truth America also
believes there is a difference between
right and wrong and right matters here
but there is more truth matters right
matters but so does decency decency
matters when the president smears a
patriotic public servant like Murray
ivanovitch in pursuit of a corrupt aim
we recoil when the president mocks the
disabled a war hero who is a prisoner of
war or a Goldstar father we are appalled
because decency matters here and when
the president tries to coerce an ally to
help him cheat in our elections and then
covers it up we must say enough enough
he has betrayed our national security
and he will do so again
he has compromised our elections and he
will do so again you will not change him
you cannot constrain him he is who he is
truth matters little to him what's right
matters even less and decency matters
not at all I do not ask you to convict
him because truth or right or decency
matters nothing to him but because we
have proven our case and it matters to
you truth matters to you right matters
to you you are decent he is not who you
are
in Federalist 55 James Madison wrote
that there were certain qualities in
human nature qualities I believe like
honesty right and decency which should
justify our confidence in
self-government he believed that we
possessed sufficient virtue that the
chains of despotism were not necessary
to restrain ourselves from destroying
and devouring one another it may be
midnight in Washington but the Sun will
rise again I put my faith in the
optimism of the founders you should too
they gave us the tools to do the job a
remedy as powerful as the evil it was
meant to constrain impeachment they
meant it to be used rarely but they put
it in the Constitution for a reason for
a man who would sell out his country for
a political favor for a man with
threatened the integrity of our
elections for a man who invite foreign
interference in our affairs for a man
who would undermine our national
security and that of our allies for a
man like Donald J Trump they gave you a
remedy and they meant for you to use it
they gave you an oath and they meant for
you to observe it we have proven Donald
Trump guilty now do impartial justice
and convict him I yield back
the majority leader is recognized mr.
Chief Justice I ask unanimous consent
the Senate sitting on a it's a court
record of impeachment stand adjourned
under the previous order without
objection so ordered
I suggest the absence of a quorum
mr. Alexander
[Music]